one game that is maybe the most famous
back grain combination of all time do
you want me to show you really quickly
yes please
it is idiot now there's a lot of history
behind this game that's fascinating this
is a very funny thing about chess okay a
lot of the most famous games that have
been played a lot of the most beautiful
games
we're later found to be artificially
constructed or they were played in some
coffee shop where like the person who
was on the receiving end of the
brilliancy was seeing that the
brilliancy was possible and he was
deliberately kind of going for it just
to be like on the receiving end of
history man that's some white cooking
[ __ ] right there well but but then these
games are passable this game was played
in the most serious tournament was
played in the World Championship and if
the player who lost the game would have
lost then he would have lost his entire
career but in reality they were
cigar-smoking like Frenchmen like for
whiskey shots and oh you know use of
civilian CII will allow you because I'm
gentleman you know to create some
brilliant moves so that was more the
atmosphere some of these games in this
game actually it's disputed whether this
game was actually played or whether it
was invented by the player playing white
okay but still the fact remains it's a
beautiful game
[Music]
so this game allegedly was played in New
Orleans in 1920 between a guy named
Edwin Ziegler Adams kind of a master
level player not very famous and the
player playing black actually on the
receiving end of this brilliancy was
famous one of Mexico's first
grandmasters Carlos Tory Repetto now
already what makes this game suspicious
is the fact that the way in which Tory
lost the game would convince one given
the kind of player he was that he was
almost under the influence I'm gonna
paste the position in here do you see
the position change on your stream yep
awesome so in this position Adams is
playing white Tory is playing black what
immediately jumps out at you about why
I'm showing you this position back rank
possibility I had now you see this
rakonin and how much tension there is
surrounding it there's two defenders two
attackers
now what hypothetically kind of tactic
could you come up with to ensure that
rook takes the ATIS checkmate I
mentioned to you a distraction tactic
what does that mean
that meaning keeping his his attention
elsewhere so he doesn't see that he's
only a couple moves from checkmate so in
a position like this maybe for white
you'd be looking to try and sack a piece
somewhere so that way you'd have one
less defender right bingo so you want to
distract this Queen or potentially this
rook from its defense over ei right at
all costs then this moves gonna be
checkmate okay so here Adams announced a
series of absolutely stunning
distraction sacrifices one after the
other he chases away black's queen which
desperately tries to remain hooked to
the rook on e8 and it starts with the
move Queen to g4 which is nothing
technically really to write home about
so nice move but you see the point right
if I take the Queen this is checkmate
yeah now very importantly if black tries
to take the row Connie - is it possible
now to take the Queen or does it get
checkmate it as well no it doesn't get
checkmated because the knight starting
exactly so that's a very important
concept so Tory says no problem
I'm not gonna fall for your little
stupid tricks I'm going Queen to be five
okay keeping contact with the rock on
the eight now and also I would point out
if you try to chase the Queen away for
the pawn black Oh actually yeah black
will take the rook with the Queen and
after rook takes c2 black is a back rank
checkmate of his own right which move in
particular it's going to see one rook c1
shack and then 91 and now and now you're
taking the nape and then you're taking
the roof no there's a matter what a way
because it is it does matter this is
Jack needs an x-ray checkmate if you
take the rook first and I'm defending
the knight so you got to do it in that
order okay okay no sense in this
position and this is a move all watch
you find or try to find it Adams made
allegedly made an absolutely frickin
stunning move it's another distraction
sacrifice but I'll give you a hint it
sacrifices the Queen both to the rook
and to the Queen it's an incredible
incredible move
okay I guess couldn't he'd you know give
the Queen's okay I was gonna say cuz
couldn't you just take that rook on see
a riot
almost but the problem is I escaped with
the rook and simultaneously I'll take
the Queen so it's it's a distraction
sacrifice you're trying to get the Queen
away from its contact with the rook
there is actually only one way to do
that and it uses yc4 right bingo nice if
rook takes c4 what happens yeah but
you're getting Chuck maybe exactly and
if Queen takes before you're also
getting checkmated look at this frickin
filthy move so and if again if rook
takes c2 then you can choose between
taking the Queen are taking this rope
and delivering checkmate so Tory once
again is like no problem I'm bringing
blue Queen back to the seven and the
moves can be repeated here with Queen g4
queen bee five but again Adams finds yet
another absolutely stunning distraction
sacrifice your honor also find it again
the same exact idea
another stunning move because he just go
to c7 yes Wow
Queen c7 okay Queen B five now he goes
one moment now he goes a four because
again if you take the pawn with the same
idea then Queen takes c2 is very
unpleasant and we've already discussed
this right this is checkmate so by going
for a four he split the Queen's body in
front of the ropes so if we take c2 what
what does white simply do now well now
you can obviously defend against this so
you could just take the rook or you
could take the Queen well you can't say
taking the Queen wins the Queen because
either piece the black takes leads to
background check right if you take the
rook first black will take your rope and
then I'll take your queen and the null
because that kind of I know I went fast
through this yeah I guess that's another
thing I struggle with is knowing the
right order because to me when I look at
this it seemed even but yeah see now
like and that's something we'll work on
through the lens of tactics so after
Queen takes a four atoms pushes up his
rook to e4 same idea attacking the Queen
Queen to b5 and now the final move the
car
yet another distraction sacrifice after
which the Queen finally runs out of air
can you tell me this move
hmm I was gonna say c5 but that doesn't
work okay close just look at it's it's
it's the same theme just look at all of
the potential squares and try to
distract the Queen and again don't
tunnel vision to like only this file
look at the entire board every square
make sure that the Queen keeps this
square and protection and like this
square is also protected so how do you
make a Queen move to defend both of
those squares c6 see you're very close
now queen c6 is a brilliant move the
problem is I can take with my queen yeah
fortunately the Queen keeps contact with
the real Connie but so you when you take
with the Queen taking with the pawn
doesn't that's that gives you the same
desired effect right this is it's a move
your it's maybe your resistance you
because I still think you're thinking in
only one direction
and it's a move to the left yeah okay oh
yeah that immediately threw it off
because I looked at d6 taking that pawn
but that that doesn't do anything
yeah that's taking a pawn but which fun
do you take it's taking on f7 right whoa
taking a pawn but you're you're getting
off task here you have to distract this
[ __ ] Queen from the e8 square yeah
okay so the only other poem that can do
that though is well b7 attacks the Queen
it also defends that so it's got to be
b7 yes finally the game is Queen B so
sorry to be so pester e about you
finding this book but again I just want
to like hammer this point home back ring
tactics are like after hanging beaches
probably the second most important but
let's review this from the start
before I grab I grab my foot so he
starts with Queen G for Queen C for
Queen c7 a for distracting the Queen
in order to bring the rook up to e4
queen has to move to b5 and he slowly
kind of cuts the arrow further and
further and further until the Queen is
fully deprived of squares and that is
this Adam story game that's one of the
most famous applications of background
tactics and this game nobody knows
whether it was actually played New
Orleans nobody knows what tournament was
being held at the time why this Mexican
player was in New Orleans so there's a
lot of mystery about this game as well
that's kind of interesting so did they
reside at this point you resigned to RA
Toria residance all themes uncheck forks
all puzzles you're in the rating range
let's increase the rating range a little
bit let's do 0-2 to 1200 you see where
it says rating range up at the top so go
back like back to the home sorry and
above the training Oh click on learning
and then click yeah one 1000 maybe or we
could do the rated feature like whatever
you prefer yeah but this is what I want
like zero to 1200 okay yeah that's fine
so now just go through everything
normally or is there something special
you want me doing here
um actually scratch that let's go back
to 800 my bad 800 800
you immediately looked at this and said
yo Charlie that you will solve it but
it's less of a priority there'll be some
endgame puzzles if we do 1200 but you
can solve this one let me give her a
whirl you know I think you will solve
this a nice but this is more of an
endgame puzzle that's why not because
there's like that hard necessarily so
what's going on here well right now
we're looking to a passed pawn right
mm-hmm
so by pushing B 3 that gives him the
passed pawn which I don't want to do so
the only ER what was that yeah if you
play b3 he takes it he promotes this
point so if you go 8-4 here yeah
actually what you need to do is you need
to identify the fact that he's got the
weak pawns and you need to advance your
King to take them
even before playing it before playing
you for you to try to slam that King
over to d4 so that it wins the pawn on
c4 okay so then you just immediately
start going exactly bingo and now yep
and you simply take the point well we
can continue you feel like that's do but
I feel like that's a that was like an
exactly at 1200 graded puzzle okay that
makes sense that wasn't too bad it just
I guess I don't know how crucial order
is cuz I was thinking a four first which
is right so was that loud right that
would have allowed him to bring his King
into the center and shoulder out your
King now this puzzle is is quite quite
easy so walk me through the solution
okay so immediate things he's now pushed
up upon looking to develop Bishop out to
the side feeling kind of the bishop as
for hiding pieces he doesn't have any he
has nothing developed so I guess what
we're looking for in this puzzle is a
way of finishing this off so putting in
check here and then just right here yes
oh you scared me when you said there was
nothing hanging but I guess when I say
hanging up my when we really look at
minor piece and I got that's okay yeah
okay this one's really hard Charlie I
think you should spend a couple hours on
this one this is this is a tough one huh
that looks pretty tough I think a 2600
puzzle by some sort of glitch made its
way to your Saturday felt like it it
really did but remember these would have
caused you some trouble even earlier so
now you feel like they're very easy and
you're solving them instantly by even
just a little while ago you would have
kind of labored over them yeah and
that's I think that just comes with
having played so many now at this point
no another thing that I think I struggle
with I guess with puzzles is I never
really know exactly what they're looking
for without a checkmate or just winning
pieces that's a good thing right because
during the game you also don't know
exact
what you're looking for yeah but in this
position for example do you think it's
gonna be checkmate that you're looking
for is it realistic to assume that no I
don't think there's any checkmate
possibility here so I'm looking to win a
knight is what I'm thinking I can't just
take that c4 Knight because he takes
with his knight
so I need to prep that right so I'm
thinking mm-hmm
and if you could name the move that
you're about to play it'll help me
because of the delay right so I'm
thinking f6 pawn to attack this Knight
make him get off and then I can take
that exactly you notice the relationship
between the Knights you chase off the
base night and you will either that
night or the other night very nice this
is like a 1100 rated problem okay okay
whoa okay I love this one I love this
one
so the thing I immediately notice is
playing his white white right hat and
that right now has his Knight eyeing
down a rook which is typically worth to
take but I don't know if that's what the
lesson here is to just take the better
piece I think it's probably deeper right
let's consult your intuition and what
that means is look at his King is this
King in any kind of danger if the answer
is yes then you should spend at least a
little bit of time looking for something
bigger and greater than taking the rook
I just thought it's just taking this
pawn at age 60 Arabian me yeah and then
then it's just pushing work down here to
a genie with check by the before you
switch to the next room I don't know if
you already have but if you would have
taken his rook at the start if you could
use that slider too fat to rewind back
to the start you see it's on the bottom
left of your screen there's a little
slider that you could use to get back to
the start of the problem yep oh just
using my arrow keys oh yeah that also
works so if you take the rook okay how
do you evaluate this position what
material situation do we have on the
board if you take his rook and he takes
her Knight what do you I mean I'm I'm up
a rook so I'm my mother yeah you're up a
rope just like have anything in return
for a row
okay I take his rook he takes with Queen
Queens threatening just yeah I guess
they shook oh jesus yeah I guess I was
playing as though I was like really far
up okay mm-hmm so you see it's two
pieces for a rock yep and the reality is
sometimes that's a form of tunnel vision
where you see a hanging piece let's say
a night for work and you and you don't
consider the initial material balance
remember black is up a piece here so
taking a rook is its big [ __ ] you know
black has the Queen a bishop and a knife
for the rook he's totally fine so if the
King safety is the real x-factor if the
King is unsafe then you have to look for
checkmate if your material is equal and
there's a hanging queen chances are you
want to hang you want to take that
painting Queen okay thanks yeah all
right good
ooh
okay this one is one where you have to
draw the game Thank You night store for
the Sun yeah I think this is oh well
what I was thinking and now I see why
that doesn't work is by pushing that
Pawnee take with Bishop I'd take his
pawn but that's clearly not it that's
almost it you the problem is if you push
her pot up he takes with the beginning
so you have to stop him from taking with
a king you have exactly the right idea
and then you come back for the other
pond and you treat it yeah it so this is
what I have to just bring my eating out
at first so it's just Chi to minim
pushing and he's actually in zoo bomb
like remember Zhuge swung is a position
where every move he makes harms his
position yeah exactly
Oh what you took but you didn't take the
bishop I I immediately recognized that
you just wasted trying it no problem
it's just sort of automatic reaction I
get that yeah that's another endgame
problem which you saw it's good another
signal this is another one where you
have to do zoogs one we've talked about
this very briefly but this is a good
time to kind of deepen our knowledge of
what Zhuge Vong means so in this
position here I obviously can't touch
anything from A to D everything's just
stopped on that position I also can't
maneuver my way over there to do
anything
so obviously the action comes from F to
H so I the natural push here is pawn to
g4 soap on a g4 and thanks JW yeah
basically creates a mass trade now can
you remember what week I don't remember
if I tell you this term the King on that
for and the King on f6 position that's
the opposition now why is opposition so
great
opposite is great because if that you
force blacks King to move if he moves to
the right then you move to the left and
penetrate if he moves to the last you
move to the right and penetrate so you
empty waiting move in order to pass the
turn to your opponent and g4 has not
accomplished that because it gives them
a chance to take the pawns exactly yeah
totally
so great so then that one in here and
then yeah yeah okay
couple more ooh this is a good problem
on thank you dreamer for the 500 bids
for the fat 500 position say what is
going on in this position uh he's
defending himself against the back
ranked taking he's got the Queen
defending the rook the bishop attacking
my queen which is also defending the
rook in the next right here exactly good
observation
but you failed to identify one other
x-ray maybe you're about to not to jump
the gun here for black side the x-rays
the pawn coming through my pawn here but
I don't think that's it so notice the
rook on g1 it's x-raying the rook on e
one that's all I'm gonna say but I want
you to actually find the mo of things
Easton oh wait I think I see it it's
just pushing Queen first he takes with
rook then I take with Rocco Queen f1
check exactly and noticing that the rook
is actually defending the f1 square like
consider the rook on you want almost
like a ghost
yeah but 1100 rated problem very nice
okay let's do two or three more and then
maybe we'll jump back in for a few last
games sounds good but you can see the
improvement in your tactics I know
you're always you know gonna be
unsatisfied with where you are which is
totally natural but I just want to
remind you how much more complicated
these tactics are than what you used to
solve and struggle yeah true ok this is
a time this is a tough one this is a to
move combination so I think I see it
it's pushing Queen first he goes to h2
then I'm pushing rook to e1 if he takes
I take Queen if he doesn't then I'm
checkmating it agent I think you're
actually GM like I am I am legitimately
impressed right now I have a smile on my
face and I'm not faking it
damn you found it immediately Queen B
one rook e1 tappable Manor giving up the
Queen that's right nice I'm pumped
let's go let's do let's do two more
okay I mean you can decide him anyone
I'm not your [ __ ] puppet I suggest
that we do okay this one's another kind
of very tricky one because it's an you
haven't really seen this beam before
well let's see if you can find it the
first thing I thought of was to go to c6
to hopefully look to cut off the patty
promotion and then that also lets me
push my pawn
imagine what black would do is go to b4
and do the same thing exactly and this
would be a draw because both sides would
stop the opposing pawns from promoting
so you need some sort of a tactic here
and to find it you need to pay attention
to the other side of the war the contact
that the King is making with a rook on
g4 mm-hmm what tell me how can you use
that contact in some way well it cuts
off a retreat he can't come down a rank
he can't go to the rank 4 here but I
have no way of like putting him in check
to force him up you say that but there
is do you mean the rook or the King I
was talking about King yeah well there
actually is you're thinking exactly in
the right way it's just a tactic you
have to be ready to like I said make
some concessions you can't win the rook
straight away but you can orchestrate a
trade of Brookes here
it is a very unusual and very important
tactical motif the reason you're not
seeing is because you're too attached to
keeping the rook on d6 alive but take
the rook on g4 at all costs here
the only way I see to do that is by
sacking the rook is that just that going
right there to g6 I think but why
because then your pawn will promote
faster than his fun and more
specifically your king will be able to
stop his pawn his game will not be able
to stop yours so how can you recognize
when your pawns gonna be first this is
just because of the position on the
board since I'm on five he's on fire yep
a little further the reality is he could
have pushed his pawn instead of trying
to bring his king over and then you
would have need to actually take a move
in order to stop the pawn with your king
Thank You Charlotte says enough for the
raid so it's our methods of determining
I never use them I literally brute force
calculate my weight I go here he goes
there I go here he goes there who
promotes first there's an entire
category of tactics that are known
sometimes as pawn races which involve
the calculation of multiple promotions
what happens with both sides make a
queen there's a lot of cool stuff that
can happen there okay yeah that makes
sense I guess that's just an area I need
to work on I don't see it too often
exactly and you know everything is your
time let's do one more
sounds good
this is actually a good problem because
because it speaks to a question that
you'd asked earlier so I don't think
this puzzle is looking for a checkmate
there is no position here I can deliver
a check what I have here though is this
Queen that's now open for my rule
exactly you just take the queen your
upper for look and then you checkmate
them like how you did against a lot of
it by going to d7 and then to h7 can you
see that me over yes you've got motif
with a rook and Bishop like that mm-hmm
all right good so significant
improvement in the tactics there's a
couple of different themes that that
will need to deepen our work on in
particular one thing that we can do
maybe for the next lesson I can prepare
some some positions on the topic of
pawns and pieces that are already
defended but you can still kind of win
them it's what I said earlier you know
what I mean like that fork you had on T
for which you shied away from because
the pawn on c2 there was defended but in
reality it's attacked more than it's
defended so these types of tactics I
sort of want to continue working with
you on but overall the improvement is
absolutely that's how do you feel
solving these do you feel more confident
absolutely he is laying the caro-kann
defense
well he's not playing it very well it's
a potential progression of the caro-kann
and if it is should I just play the d4
ya know D for this is called the gurga
needs a defense I don't think he know
you see shied away from that too now
again this is an example of where you
can just to stick to principles and he
can screw around as much as he wants but
if you stick to the development
principles nothing is going to get to
this is some this is some wild play
right now you know I've never seen this
behind the wheel here so develop your
pieces now the bishop on f1 what's its
most active square it's your favorite
one my favorite mate squarely your
favorites I'm sorry I missed what you
said did you say
what is your question had a LightSquared
bishop where should you develop it sorry
yeah so I was just gonna bring it over
there to see if I'm sorry I didn't mean
it delay there no here a good bro yeah
and I'm anticipating he might play
Bishop g4 yup and please tell me you
remember what to do now well I can't do
legal strap so this is when I need to
look this is a semi legal in this exact
position you had this move you draw the
King out and then you check him okay so
I don't remember the progression do I do
tonight first to prep it enough that is
between exactly you have to think about
it this way the knight is pinned so the
only way you can move the knight is if
it's check how do you want it straight
the check you take the pawn bingo yeah I
just so I knew what you wanted I didn't
remember what all this thing Winton
think think I'm not gonna tell you
anything I want you to find the move
well the first thing I notice is e6 for
my knight that attacks the bishop at a
taxes Queen this is an area we need to
work on because you have something a lot
better than anything you're looking for
right now look at that King you have
checkmate my friend thank you for the
bits hqk don't limit yourself to the
sixth ring look at the whole board look
at all of the possibilities remember
you've taken out his bishop so the light
squares are weak oh Jesus Christ yeah oh
it happens yep Jesus yeah yeah good so
how do you find something like this how
would I find some like this he's not
developed any of his pieces whenever
that's the case you have to start
looking for these moves you're always on
the lookout for stuff like checkmate yep
I didn't even consider dropping all the
way to c8 I was still just looking for a
knight checker friend another thing
you're looking at that e6 we're sorry to
cut you off
oh good but still that was well that was
short how about one more yeah it's fine
that guy probably quit playing chess
after that knows it was a wacky opening
though el-masri is gonna try to become
an old master in something else other
than chess yeah have you ever seen
oh I'm sure you've seen an opening like
that is that a real opener is it just
like his first two moves constitute an
opening called the gergan it's a defense
named after a georgian chess grandmaster
but he didn't play it correctly like i
don't think he knew he was stumbling on
this you know why does every single
opening have like a named a tied to it
or just an opening so bad that nobody
uses it i think every first move has a
name but some are like like the move
knight a 3n move one is called the
sodium attack because na is the symbol
for sodium so that's like a smurf some
don't have names on like move to most
most openings I move one have names
but that doesn't mean the person who
invited them is like it is smart I think
sometimes the person who invented them
is crazy there is a very funny story I
will tell you right after this game odd
before we might wrap up about opening
names and it's like something that maybe
nobody in my chat even knows even the
people who are experienced ok so good
development so far continue to develop
your pieces yeah I don't need to chase
off this Bishop right now right it's not
really doing no matter you're gonna keep
going normal absolutely you could but
it's not pitting me out if you if you
please Bishop g5 that Knight is closer
to your king so in that regard I would
then I would play h6 so that's something
I need to look for is proximity yeah
broke somebody to the king the closer
stuff happens around your king the more
attentive he need to be to this kind of
stuff
yeah and he's played the Rui Lopez he's
played the Spanish defense which is at a
grand master level this move Bishop to
b5 that he played is the most popular
move it's the move that I play myself
with white but he doesn't really know
how to handle it is the thing well
interesting mm-hmm it's the most
interesting thing I've ever seen I
disagree you're very interesting man
Daniel you very my question appreciate
the compliment even after all the times
I [ __ ] on you ok he's taken you see now
he's taken unprovoked so the move a six
you actually saved time by not playing
it yeah opens up the B file and I like
that you don't care that you quote
unquote ruined your pawn structure
because it just doesn't matter that's
just one doubled pawn nobody cares about
it you have the two bishops also yeah
that was something I was super worried
about like early on but I guess over the
time we've spent playing these just
realize it's not that big of an issue so
this position is one I had a question on
there's this one where I trade the
bishops here or do I just want to drop
it back and drop it back because you
don't want to open up the F file for him
remember you do that yourself you don't
want to open up the FL instead if you
drop it back to be
than you and if he takes it you can open
up the eight file for your Brooke
okay so then that's what we're looking
for it got you Thanks chemistry so then
if he does take this bishop I want to
take with the a pawn instead of the C
pawn either would notify neither has
both have their pros and cons but I
would I would say could be a pawn but he
what now Rosa what what do you what what
are what are you thinking about now uh
so I still haven't developed most of my
pieces I still have been cast old I
still have my bishop not doing anything
I was gonna bring bishop to the most
active square at g4 bingo
pushes a pawn if he pushes the pawn then
you remember he weakens his position you
can keep the band etc etc he probably
will play the move aged me so that would
be my guess
and then in that position I don't
remember what we discussed do I just
drop the Bishop back holding the pin yes
exactly
okay and then if he pushes the pawn
again that'd just be a huge mistake yeah
exactly because then you can sacrifice
that night in a way that we talked about
many times you remember that right
you're talking about my knight right
yeah well I mean yeah he just plays kind
of an empty motor q1 which allows you to
keep developing yes and I want a castle
so castling short that I ordered a dish
with a 10 out of 10 level of spice so if
I die you know this has been fun yeah
bet it's always fun
yeah it's a tough position for your
opponent to figure out what to do in
because you've got the pin going you
know you've got good coordination with
your pieces and a lot of people lose
their cool here and play g-force so if
he placed you for what do you do in that
position that's what I'm throwing knight
on it right because I'm going right
before creating that permanent bin the
the bishop to the Queen and then he no
longer has the support for his Knight
yeah yes total position for white to
kind of handle them so it's hard to get
rid of that pin actually because he's
given away his LightSquared bishop
yeah
you might lose on time at this rate you
actually have more time than your
opponent I can't believe it
yeah well this has just been like a
super standard game so far so all of
these moves are moves that I've seen
like a million times now - too modest
well basically um okay now he pens you
yeah in this position do I chase that
off with h6 yes absolutely because now
if you boy G 5 then he won't be able to
take it with a knight because his night
is finished so your pin is better than
his my pen is better than your pan okay
I get yeah he's probably just gonna take
night so then I just I'm probably just
gonna pre move take back that we good
very good
so while he's taking a million years to
think I can tell that story there's an
opening a chest called the Domino's
defense actually named about named in
honor what uncle well okay let's let's
focus on you okay so he's just trying to
hold this pin pushing mine to g5 that's
better now right because you can't take
with the night exactly and you basically
excommunicating as bishop yeah
to be fair though I don't think someone
at this level would have even thought to
take that with the night even if there
was right exactly I see okay now you
have this fun on g5 can you continue the
it well what comes to mind that this is
a great position to practice finding
moves in somewhat undefined positions so
the first thing go ahead
I was just gonna say the first thing I
thought was just immediately pushing up
one more time if he takes with pawn that
opens up a CH for me a little bit then I
can look to try and get a queen back
there maybe try and find a mate but yeah
I love it
I like this up that would be my second
this would be my second candidate move
so you can go ahead and do that what was
the first candidate I'll play this was
the one you were thinking of the first
to us to open up that F file and in
order to open up they have filing you to
play a five what neat what do you need
to do in order to play a five bingo but
you can actually do both you can play g4
and after HG you can take with a knight
so that you'd then prepare at five so
you can get the best of both worlds that
makes sense the only to the drawback I
saw of this move though it frees the pin
thanks I'm glad you mentioned that and
that's why you should take on g4 with
the night because if you took with the
bishop he would bring his bishop back to
h4 as you said yeah
yeah so he has a decision to make
obviously so anyway this damiano's
defense was named after a 16th century
chess author called Damiano Italian and
it's a terrible terrible move that's
been refuted and everybody assumes - who
is this Damiano idiot who developed this
this terrible move like he basically
lost a lot of players game well who
would recommend something like that
right well what very few people know is
that Damiano actually refuted that line
in his book he actually told their
reputation but sadly people started
calling it the Damiano z' defence anyway
but the reality is he was the one who
who said it was terrible so that's one
of the many and justices that have been
made on a chess world so what made it so
bad what was the actual show you after
the game maybe okay I'd like to take a
peek at that yeah this is something you
should actually have slick or actually
played it against you but I can show you
the reputation then because it's just
way too long I get you all right so now
the pin is broken here like what was the
second reason you took on g4 with the
night the plan that I proposed what was
it oh we were pushing up to f5 we want
to do that now open up that file okay
again don't fall into the trap of
thinking that that all attacks take
place over the course of like two moves
you have to spend a lot of time
sometimes accumulating pieces that makes
sense yeah I think it's another thing
you need to work on as well and here
once you bring your rook and then you
can bring your queen and you can stack
the Queen and the rook on the F file
things are gonna start imploding very
soon for white holding tension is
another area I struggle with when the
board stayed stagnant for a long time
with a lot of pieces just defending each
other and maybe like loosely threatened
something I have a hard time knowing
what moved to play next so I'll end up
writing like an empty ward that makes
sense and sometimes you do have to play
and you know an empty move sometimes you
kind of want to bide your time okay so
you goes 90 to what now I still want to
free up this F file so that doesn't
change anything I'm just taking yeah
and then bring more of your pieces in
and basically what you want to do is you
want to decide on the best ideal square
for the queen first where does the Queen
belong so its harmoniously placed in
relationship with the rook that's just
going right up there to f6 absolutely
yeah it's AB six and then you could
slide it over to g6 potentially and then
you could slowly bring in both of your
ropes this attack is gonna be freaking
epic once it actually uncoils he's gonna
be in huge trouble
thanks for the hundred pence opener but
yeah this is just horrendous for white
okay so I didn't have a question on this
my bishop over here on b6 is looking
right at that f2 pawn taking well I
guess that doesn't work he just takes
back with Bishop and then I'm I'm not
really winning anything there he'll do
steak with King yeah but you should
notice it in case he ever moves his
bishop or in case you ever might
sacrifice something for his Bishop on g3
such that after that you can then take
on f2 so that's something you should
keep in the back of your head but for
now you need to keep accumulating pieces
on the Kings side what comes the Alliant
so now I well what I thought of was
setting up Alekhine's gun so I just
bring rook up and then push the other
rook on f8 excellent I love that you
remember that what kinds gun - that's
exactly what I would do
yeah
notice how like methodically are
preparing this attack like patiently
bringing every single piece in and then
it's all gonna be worth it in the guns
Yamini Oh game analysis will still
happen like probably maybe even later
let it say but we'll see
definitely this week okay he's trying to
reinforce the pontiff he's defending
well it's just not enough okay so this
doesn't change anything I still want f8
here for a long canal ik on its gun you
mentioned that name don't disappoint me
you promised me an Alec eins gun now I
want to see it oh it's [ __ ] coming
don't you worry about don't get my
specialty technically the alkynes gun I
think is the rooks first and then the
Queen but I think I think we'll forgive
ya it's fair enough it kind of looks
like a gun barrel like it you know just
shot something out with the Queen like
little crown they're exploding [ __ ] you
have to really like change your
perspective to like a four-year-old to
see that yeah well that's what I was
attempting to do okay well he's
attacking you Queen where should the
Queen now park itself so that again is
harmoniously placed in relationship with
the ropes just bringing him up to f4 but
the good thing about the queen is they
can act in concert the rooks are already
doing the job of controlling the F
father you don't actually really need
the Queen on the F file anymore where
would it be better suited to be how can
it x-ray the king yeah I just want to
put it on G so I'd want g6 exactly
exactly and now you're actually ready to
start sacrificing you are already
threatening a crushing sacrifice that
basically breaks through do you see what
it might be and that's actually another
benefit of putting the Queen on g6 well
the benefit so when I see positions like
this the first thing I noticed is how
that pollens not gonna be able to take
if I take something on f3 bingo that's
exactly what you want to do okay but
then you have a discover check that wins
literally everything in the position so
I guess this is back to something we
talked about earlier the order of things
I don't I don't recognize what order
these things should happen and so I can
see them I just don't know what are the
possible orders like what are you
thinking of do
what - well like first you can move the
night away and then take on f3 or you
can take on after it move the night away
the question is right which is better
yeah well normally discovered checks can
be very devastating so if he moved the
night away you give him more flexibility
if you take on f3 you normally want to
choose the more forcing move okay now
you could take on f2 with a knight that
also wins the game on this but in this
case it doesn't really matter but taking
on f3 is a little bit more precise do
you see what I'm saying kind of I guess
they just don't recognize why it's
better so right now the optimal movies
is taking that f3 now we'll work on this
we'll talk about this game and then
we'll work on this in a future session
let me write this down I will choose I
will construct a set problems on this
topic and help you with this okay
order of operations basically
yeah but do you see that this that this
move wins do you see how effective it is
is it more a question of or is it more
question of which is more effective well
you think yes are strong it's always
what's more effective for me because I'm
never quite sure yeah that makes sense
well tackle this for sure okay so now
it's going in with the knight for this
Discoverer check I'm taking Queen next
yep yep sorry for the chewy
exactly and he's got 50 seconds but
that's not even his biggest problem he's
got a blue his King and the funny thing
is if he moves and remember you called
this you mentioned that Bishop on v6
making contact to the f2 pond so now you
get to reap the rewards of that so in
this position so he tries to win your
queen and technically he does but you
can take a million things in return for
the Queen so just take the free stuff
here okay so the the free stuff oh I
guess freeze objective so it's rook on a
one with my yeah and then he takes your
queen and you take his other okay at the
end of the day you're just gonna be up a
full rook okay okay he doesn't even do
that it gives you the other road for
free - okay you know I just take it with
the bishop exactly and that's it
yeah and now I want to see you finish
them off on your own you know he could
have taken with the night bed right he
doing I think he's tilted she's way too
tilted to see moves like that
okay so then the next move here
I want to look to set up a checkmate so
to me it looks like moving rook up here
to ff3 to take this pawn this one you
can already I mean you're good enough
where where you can follow your gut
instincts in these positions and it's
normally gonna be good enough yeah so in
here yeah I can
it's not made though coming up to g4
with Queen that doesn't made or not made
in one though so again don't fall into
this trap of trying to find the fastest
maid and then losing on time just like I
do stuff and get his King cornered and
then you'll finally made okay yeah I
guess I'll just play it out just you
know pin his Bishop on g3 whatever you
want to do to get to him there - then
here you're off of Queen and a rogue
anything wins here okay but pushing this
pushing this rook check he takes enough
to check and then you take the knight
and then it's mate you see how easy you
found the red move but you're hesitating
so we what we also will do is a speed
technique round where I'll give you
completely winning positions against me
and you're gonna have to win them in a
certain period of time okay now you
would have wanted to be careful with yet
if you didn't have any pawns left that
would have been stalemate but since he
had he does have fun pawns left that's
over oh yeah oh [ __ ] that's another
thing I need to be aware of
[Music]
it door - is ready in like ten minutes I
ordered I ordered it a couple days ago
in time I'd [ __ ] you not this the
restaurants like four minutes from our
live it was ready in like 12 minutes
I've never separately want that yeah I
mean it's definitely why though man
you're basically walking distance from
it yeah this is I mean that's what I
liked about this is a lot of places
nearby also they know it's a grandmaster
you know Charlie so I know you wouldn't
understand or you wouldn't know but you
just open your zoo and shout when they
know who they're serving you know the
delivery occurs quite a kind of fast the
old scholars made of delivering to Geum
Daniel
exactly